Hello, everyone.
My name is Dr.
Patel. I'm one of
the pediatricians.
If you don't know
me, I graduated at
NICOM in 2021, so
I'm a fellow alum.
I'm excited to be
back and talking to
you guys about history
and physical exam
skills for pediatric
patients. This
is part one. There
will be a part two.
This one covers
birth to five years
old. The next one
will cover six to 10.
So let's get started.
Okay, so these are
learning objectives
and all the things
that we will talk
about, starting with
basic newborn visit,
interviewing, history
taking, newborn
growth development,
vaccine schedule,
how to examine a
newborn, physical exam
pathologies that
are commonly found,
when children to
toddlers of up to five
years of age, what
questions do you
ask, what the AP
screenings recommend,
and tips and tricks
on how to examine
young children, which
I know is difficult
if you haven't
examined kids before.
Okay, so at
delivery, you want to
find out their
APGAR score. So they
usually get designated
APGAR scores at
one minute and five
minutes of life.
This was designated
by Dr. APGAR. She
came up with this
system, and since then
we've been using it.
This component is
of five parts. So
we have appearance,
pulse, grimace, activity,
and respiration.
And the point system
is from zero, one to
two, two being the
most points you can
get, one being the
middle and zero being
none. So we go through
each system and we
look at the baby and
make sure we score
them based off of
what we see. So A is
for appearance. So we
look at the baby and
see if they have any
cyanosis or bluing
of their skin or bluish
tint to their skin.
Usually babies will
score a one on this
grading because
very, very rarely do
newborn babies have a
perfectly pink body.
It's very, very common
to have acrocyanosis
as a newborn infant,
and that can last up
to a couple days, which
is a normal finding.
If they're cyanotic
all over or very pale,
they get zero points
for that. For pulse,
anything over 100 beats
per minute, which is
what we want in a baby,
gives you two points.
Anything less than
100 gives you one
point, and no pulse
at all gives you zero
points. For grimace, if
they're floppy and not
responding at all,
that gives you zero
points. If they have a
little bit of response
when you stimulate them,
that gives them one
point. And if they're
crying and doing all
the things without
even being stimulated,
that gives them two
points. For activity,
same, active motion,
vigorous, that you
give them two points
for it. If they have
their legs flexed and
legs flexed, usually
we give them one. And
then if there's no
movement at all, or
they're just flaccid,
we give them zero
points. In terms of
respiration, it really,
we are looking for
consistency. So if
they have a strong,
vigorous cry and
consistent breathing, we
give them a two. If
they're irregular
breathing, so they
breathe, breathe, breathe,
stop for a good amount
of time, breathe once,
stop again. That's
called irregular
breathing. And for that,
they usually get a one.
Or they have signs of
respiratory distress.
Zero points they get for
no breathing
effort at all.
So usually this gives
us an idea of how,
what the condition
is in which the
baby was born. So
severely depressed is
anywhere from zero
to three. Moderately
depressed would be
four to six. And
excellent condition
would be seven to 10.
Usually we get two
EPCAR scores, so a one
-minute life and
five-minute life to
determine where they
are. If they're scoring
very low in the first
minute or even five
minutes, we continue
to score them every
five minutes until
we get a better score
or we get them the
help that they need.
These are the normal
oxygenation saturation
levels for a
newborn infant. So
you'll see at five
minutes of life if it's
perfectly normal
for them to have 80
to 85 percent of O2,
SpO2 on room air.
And this is normal to
take some time for them
to transition at the
initial newborn visit.
So say you're at the
clinic and you're
seeing a newborn baby for
the first time. They're
seeing a doctor and
you're their first
doctor. You want to
figure out some questions.
So for mom, you want
to ask mom or dad, you
want to ask about
the birth history. So
when there are any
complications during
delivery, what was the
mode of delivery? Were
they born via vaginal
delivery or C-section?
Did they come out with
their head first or
were they breech,
which means that their
butt or their legs
were coming out first?
Usually in those
cases, they'll do
a C-section. So
putting the pieces
together will
help you determine
what they did and
why they did it.
If they have a birth
weight, that would be
great to know. And
then definitely you
want to ask for gestational
age. So were they
37 weeks, which is
considered full term,
or anything above, or
were they less than
that? Because if
they're *********, they
could have different
pathologies and different
things that you want
to look out for.
Did the baby need
any oxygen when
they were born?
Did they go to the
NICU? Did they
get phototherapy?
And if mom knows
her GBS status,
that would also be
great. or if she
had any other diseases
during pregnancy,
that's also
important to know.
The last thing I'd
like to find out is
whether the baby passed
their hearing screen,
the CCHD, which is
the congenital cardiac
heart screening, if
they got their hepatitis
B, erythromycin or
vitamin K vaccine,
and their blood type
and Coombe status.
The reason I like to
know these things is
because if the patient
has failed their
hearing screen, that
I need to refer them
to audiology, which
could indicate like
a congenital
infection, like a torch
infection. If they did
not pass their CCHD,
then do they have
an underlying
congenital cardiac issue?
So in this screening,
what they do is
attach a probe, like
an oxygen stat to pre
-ductal and post
-ductal. So one to the
hand and one to the
foot, and basically just
to make sure those
numbers are aligned.
If they're not,
they could indicate
something like a
coarctation of the aorta.
If they got the hepatitis
B, that's fantastic.
I also want to know
mom's hepatitis
B status. So if she
didn't have hep B, great.
If she did have hep
B, then I want to
make sure baby not
only gets hepatitis B
vaccine, but also the
immunoglobulin for hep
B, okay? They love
testing that as well.
Also, if the baby got
erythromycin, which
is the medication,
the topical medication
that helps
prevent gonorrhea
conjunctivitis, which
we'll talk about. And
then vitamin K is
super important because
it helps, is a
cofactor for a lot of
coagulation factors.
So in order to help
the newborn clot
their blood, it's very
important for them
to get vitamin K.
If parents refuse to
get vitamin K, they
do have to sign a
refusal form that states
that they understand
the risks, which
includes bleeding
into their brain, like
having a ******, and
possibly death as well.
The reason I like to
know the blood type and
the coom status is
because if there's an
ABO incompatibility,
which just means that
mom's blood is O, and
baby's blood can be A, B,
or AB. And that would
tell us that mom has
antibodies that could
have potentially
transferred over to the
baby and attacked their
blood cells. So if
that's, if there's an ABO
incompatibility and
the Coombs test is
positive, then I'm more
worried about hemolysis
in this baby and they
might have jaundice
earlier. So things to
keep out, keep in mind.
Okay. So newborns
should be gaining about
20 to 30 grams a
day, they should
double their weight
about four months, and
then they can triple
their weight in
about one year. So
remember, normal full
term babies will
actually lose about 10
% of no more than 10
% of their weight.
And it takes about
10 to 14 days to get
back to their birth
weight and then beyond.
If they're sort of
inching down, and they're
getting close to that
10% and they're already
on day like 12, I will
definitely push the
parents to, you know,
A, see me more so I
can follow this baby
more closely and B, to
either supplement the
nutrition like with
formula if they're
exclusively breastfeeding or
change the way they're
either mixing the
formula or how often
they're giving it, okay?
You also want to know
whether this baby was
born small for
gestational age or large
for gestational age.
Sorry. So that means
that if they were less
than 10th percentile
compared to other babies,
they're considered
small for gestational
age. When you're
small for gestational age,
there's two categories.
You can either be
asymmetrically small
or you can be
symmetrically small. So
asymmetrically small just
means that you spared
your head. So you
have a big head and
smaller kind of
extremities in the rest of
your body. Symmetric
means you have a small
head that's proportioned
to the rest of your
body, which is also
small. This tells you
whether there was a
problem with like a
problem that started
in the first trimester
when the baby was
developing. For example,
CMV is a torch
infection that causes
abnormalities in the fetus.
And so the child would
be symmetrically
small versus something
like preeclampsia, which
is high blood pressure,
and that prevents the
blood vessels from
passing nutrients onto
the baby, that will
usually start affecting
the baby around
second trimester, which
causes that asymmetry
in the growth. And
the baby will start to
push more blood into
their brain or their vital
organ and less towards
the rest of their
body, therefore causing
them to be smaller.
LGA means large for
gestational age.
So that means that
they're more than
90th percentile. For
either one of these
extreme cases, we
check sugars on the
babies while they're
in the hospital.
And that helps
us make sure that
they don't get
hypoglycemia.
Because brain function
is essential for
babies and glucose is
essential for brain
function so um we we
take that very important
uh we take that
very seriously okay
their head circumference
so normally at
birth uh their head
circumference should be
about 35 uh centimeters
it grows the fastest
in the newborn
period so about two
centimeters a month for
the first three months
and then it slows
down to one centimeter
a month for the next
three months and
then 2.5 centimeters
a month for six months
and then one year is
when the fontanelle
the anterior fontanelle
will fuse and
that becomes one big
skull like in adults.
Okay, during this
time, it's important
to check the newborn
screening results.
So each state has its
own newborn screen
and what diseases
are part of that
screen. We are lucky
that New York has a very
extensive list of
either metabolic and
genetic conditions
that are included.
So if there's
anything abnormal that
comes up, oh, and
this picture down here
is what the newborn
screening form looks
like. So there's
little circles and
you're supposed
to do a heel stick
and then get some
blood and that
fills up the
circle. And then
that's what they
send for testing.
If it's abnormal,
then the Department of
Health, the State
Department of Health
will call the clinic,
the hospital and the
parents and will
reiterate the urgency
of either redrawing
it, um, if it's
borderline or intervening.
Um, so it tests
for a whole bunch of
things, including PKU,
maple syrup disease,
um, galactosemia,
uh, cystic fibrosis,
hypothyroidism,
congenital adrenal
hyperplasia, um,
so many things to test
for. So it's really,
really great that
we have this. Um, if
it's normal, then the
results come, come back
in about two weeks
uh okay so you also
want to ask about
feeding so what the baby
is feeding in terms
of are they just um
getting breast milk
like exclusively breast
uh breast feeding
or um then are they
supplementing with formula
if there's something
we're doing with
formula what formula are
they using infamil
similac there's so many
different types um
are they using a soy
formula because that's
what they heard was
good uh how often
are they feeding the
baby. So, every three to
four hours is probably
typical. So, we
don't want infants to
go longer than four
hours before feeding,
especially in this
newborn period while
they're still growing.
So, if they don't wake
up in four hours, I
tell the parents to
kind of wake their
child up, okay, to feed.
You want to ask
about elimination and
urination. How many
wet diapers do they
have? How many dirty
diapers do they have?
What their poop looks
like. That's also
important. We'll talk
about that. And then I
always, always counsel
about safe sleep. So safe
sleep is a campaign
that the AAP started.
So as you can see in
this top chart, that
SIDS, which is sudden
infant death syndrome, has
really declined as
our campaign for safe
sleep has increased so
um previously like our
mothers mothers and
mothers uh thought that
sleeping on the uh on
the belly was the best
way for infants to
sleep however with more
research and more
evidence-based we now know
that the the safest
way for a baby to sleep
is actually on their
backs without any um
without any extraneous
pillows or blankets or
anything that could
potentially suffocate
the child okay um they
are still SIDS cases
which is really sad um
so uh always asking about
co-sleeping uh it's
very tiring to be a
parent so um understanding
that they will get
tired but um if they
feel like they're gonna
pass they're gonna
go to sleep then they
should put the baby back
in the crib and that's
the safest place for
them um I always also
assess how the parents
are doing, because
that's a good measure
of how the baby will be
doing. I always say
happy mommy equals happy
baby. So we use the
Edinburgh postnatal
depression screening
often in the first couple
months that we see the
infant. We'll also ask
the questions of the
mother too, to make
sure that there's no
depression or psychosis.
Okay,
then let's talk about
breastfeeding. So
most cases of breastfeeding
is very safe to
do. There's only some
contraindications to
breastfeeding, which
include if mom's on
certain medications.
So a good list to look
at is this table two
that you see right
here. For prescribers,
we can use medications
and mother's milk. We
can use E-lactisania
or LactMed. Those are
all good resources
to use to figure
out if medication is
safe to breastfeed
with. For patients, they
can use mother2baby
.org or drugs.com, which
is also a good
resource for them to
determine whether the
medication that they're
using is safe while
they're breastfeeding.
So there's some baby
reasons and then
some parent reasons.
So for baby reasons,
galactosemia, which
is they're not
able to process
galactose, Um, so
they can't receive
breast milk, maple
syrup, urine disease,
and then PKU. Um,
those are all reasons
why babies cannot
get breastfed and
they have to use
very specialized
formula for them.
Parent reasons. If,
uh, the parent has
HIV one or two status,
um, it depends on
the treatment and
viral load. So for
example, if it's
uncontrolled, uh, and the
viral load is very
high and their parent
is not in any treatment,
that's when we
will say it's best
to not breastfeed at
this time until they
get to better levels.
However, in a patient
who is really well
-controlled, has been
on treatment for years,
and has low viral load,
they are able to safely
breastfeed with the
help of an infectious
disease doctor and a
lactation specialist.
So it is possible.
Some of the other
contraindications is if
the patient has
active TB or they have
HSV, ******, simplex
virus, breast lesions,
because that can
directly transfer viral
load to the baby
and cause virulemia.
Ebola, certain
medications, and then if
mom is receiving
radioactive compounds
like chemotherapy
or radiation, that's
also a contraindication
to breastfeeding.
Usually, babies will
breastfeed or formula
feed exclusively
until about four
months. That means
they cannot have
anything else, including
water during that
time. After four to
six months, they can
start doing some
purees, some solids.
Usually the
pediatricians recommend
trying one
food at a time.
But really the latest
research, like the
AAP magazine that just
came out this past
month actually said
that allergists believe
that they don't have to
do one food at a time
and they can do it
together. And the risk
of having food allergies
is pretty minimal.
After introduction
of early peanut
exposure at like six
months, we've seen
actually decline in
the peanut allergies.
So peanuts and eggs
are okay to definitely
do start earlier.
And they found that
actually can avoid, um,
causing them severe,
uh, allergies to,
to those products.
Um, by age one, they
can start doing cow's
milk. And again, you
only want to give them
a maximum of 24 ounces
a day because milk
has a lot of calcium,
which can bind to
iron, which can cause
iron deficiency in the
toddler age range. So,
um, definitely want
to make sure it's less
than the 24 ounces
of cow's milk um i
always tell parents or
mom especially to um
to continue taking
prenatal vitamins while
they're breastfeeding
um and also if they're
exclusively breastfeeding
then the baby needs
to be supplemented
with vitamin d drops
um which is really
essential for their
bones and their growth.
For stool colors, so any
type of color is fine,
you know,
green, yellow,
orange, you name
it. The colors that
pediatricians don't
want are red, white,
and black. So red
being there's blood
in the stool, which
could indicate some
sort of a cow
protein milk allergy.
Then white, which means
pale stools, which
is what you're seeing
at the top picture
here, which is usually
indication that
bilirubin is not getting
to the stool, making
me very concerned about
a biliary atresia.
And then black. So
meconium is that first
stool that they have,
and that's usually
black or dark, dark
green. And it's sticky.
It doesn't smell
though, so that's good.
But they should not
be having meconium
after they've already
passed it. They
should be transitioning
with their stools.
Just FYI, you'll see
this in rotations and
definitely on your
question stems, but
in terms of your urine,
especially in the
newborn period when
they're just starting
to breastfeed properly
and mom is still
just making enough
breast milk, you can
have a little bit of
dehydration, which leads
to urate crystals,
which are very common
in the neonatal period.
This is a picture
of what the urate
crystals look like.
Commonly, you'll get
a call from the nurse
saying that they have
blood in their urine.
And then you look
at it and they're
urate crystals and
they go away as soon
as the baby starts
hydrating well.
Okay, so these are
growth charts. So growth
charts are very, very
important. They're
our fifth vital
sign, should you call
it, for pediatricians.
We not only look at
the weight and the
length, we also look
at the head circumference
to make sure it's
growing properly.
For preterm infants,
we use the Fenton curve,
which is a different
chart. We give them
a little bit more
time to catch up as
they were born early.
You can also use the WHO.
And then we also have the
CDC growth
charts as well.
For patients with Down
syndrome, they have
their own growth chart.
And for different
sexes, like for boys
or girls, they also
have different growth
charts. So certain
diseases have different
growth charts and boys
and girls have
different growth charts.
So it's important to
look at the correct
one. And usually the
EMR or whatever your
hospital or clinic
will use will have that
information. So that
will be good. In terms
of development,
development is also super
important for assessing
a newborn and how
they're doing. So the
Denver scoring is a
great way to look at
all of them together.
So there's four
components. There is gross
motor, fine motor,
social skills, and
language. Those are four
components of development
that we usually test
for and we usually
check for in our in
our physical exam.
Obviously, in the
beginning, they're
not doing too much.
But they start
doing a lot, you
know, after the 12
month period, which
is really exciting.
So at three months,
they can do a little
bit of head propping
up like this on their
on their forearms.
They can open their
hands spontaneously,
they smile, they
have social smile, they
coo and they laugh.
By six months, they
can sit momentarily.
So sometimes they'll
use their hands to
kind of lean on. It's
called tripodting.
It's very common in a
person who's learning
how to do axial
control of their trunk.
They'll transfer
objects. So they'll take
one object and give
it to the other side.
They'll show you their
likes and dislikes
and then do a lot of
babbling, sometimes also
shrieking so they'll
be like yeah um at
nine months they're
learning how to pull to
stand so they'll grab
something and then kind
of pull themselves up
this is usually when
i recommend patients
uh parents to move
their crib uh mattress
down so that the the
baby cannot climb up
and then fall over um
the crib uh at nine
months they also start
developing the pincer
grasp which is between
your pinky and your
I'm sorry between your
ring finger uh your
first finger and your
thumb and that is called
a pincer grasp when
you can grab something
with just your your
two fingers um sort
of like a cheerio when
you can grab a cheerio
cheerio uh nine months
is also when they have
social skills like
they like to imitate a
lot of sounds uh they
can play peekaboo
because they have object
permanence which means
that they know that
if they can't see
something that means
there's still something
behind that thing uh
whereas before they'd
be like oh if you're
gone for my vision you're
gone forever i don't
know you um at 12
months they'll um gross
motor they'll walk with
one hand held they'll
release an object on
command they'll come
when called and
they'll use one or two
meaningful words like
mama directed at mom and
dada directed at dad
or vice versa um at
18 months, they'll walk
upstairs with assistance.
They'll feed themselves
with a spoon.
They like to mimic
other people's
actions, and they'll
have at least six
words. At two years
or 24 months, they
start to run. They
build a tower of
six blocks. They
play with others, and
they use two to
three-word sentences.
So this is the vaccine
schedule. We are
using the AAP guidelines
for the immunization
schedule for children
and adolescents.
So as you can
see, we start at
birth with the
hepatitis B vaccine.
We also have the
RSV immunization,
which is pretty neat.
The studies have shown
very good results in
keeping babies out of
the hospital for RSV.
And RSV can cause a
lot of respiratory
symptoms and
bronchiolitis and hypoxia.
So it's been really
helpful for those
babies. Those who are
*********, who have
chronic lung disease
or chronic problems,
the immunization has
not been shown to
be as effective as the
healthier patients,
but it's still shown
to be very good.
If mom receives the
RSV vaccine while
she's pregnant, at
least I think 14 days
before delivery,
that will confer a
lot of immunization,
like passive
immunization to the
baby and immunity. so
the baby won't need
the immunoglobulin.
So that's really nice.
So the first set
of kind of a lot
of vaccines start
at two months
where they'll get
a combination.
And remember,
these are now, not
now, but they're
in conjunction.
So Tdap is usually
with Hib, is with IPV.
So really it's two
vaccines and then an
oral vaccine, which
is that rotavirus,
which is an oral
vaccine. So two months
is a big one, four
months, six months,
and then you take a
little break and then
you get your live
vaccines like your MMR
and your varicella
starting at 12 months.
That's your first
dose. And then you
get a booster dose
at four to six years.
And then you get a
booster of your DTAP,
which is your tetanus,
diphtheria, and
pertussis after you
turn seven. So usually
around 11 years of
age. And then your
HPV, which is for
preventing cervical cancer,
can also be started
in those teenage
years. For meningococcal,
you want to give
them one at 11 and
the other dose at 16
before they go up to
college. And that's
basically it. So just
kind of review this
quickly and kind of
keep that in mind.
Okay, let's start
with the newborn exam.
This is the fun part.
So you want to start
head to toe, but in
reality, you'll see
pediatricians doing
it kind of inter
dispersed. And that is
because babies don't
exactly act always the
way you want them to.
So if they're quiet
and calm, I will listen
to the heart and
lungs first before I
go do the other exams,
which could further
than irritate them.
And then they're going
to cry and then they're
not going to shut
up for me to be able
to listen to the
heart and lungs, right?
So you want to do
the easy things first.
But what I want you
guys to take away is
doing the head-to-toe
exam. That way you
don't miss anything.
So you'll see newborn
exams are one of
those exams where we
do the most thorough
job as doctors
examining patients.
So we start with the
head. So the head is
going to be, we're
going to note the shape
of the head. And
also remember that in
newborn infants, they
don't have one big
skull. They have many
parts of the skull,
which then fuse together.
So the fontanelle
is that soft spot
that happens right
here in between the
coronal suture and the
sagittal and mytopic
suture. So this is
that opening, that
soft spot. And that
usually stays open to
about 12 to 15 months.
This can tell
you a lot into,
like basically a
window into the baby's
life. So whether
they're dehydrated, that
fontanelle can be
sunken. If it's bulging,
then maybe the baby
has meningitis or has
hydrocephalus or increased
CSF fluid, right?
So it's important
to always
feel for the fontanelle.
The posterior fontanelle
is a little bit
smaller and it closes
within the first month
of life. So it's
possible that you may
not get to feel that one
if you're not feeling
for it right when
the baby is born
because that one closed
a little bit earlier.
Then about the shape.
So you can have what's
called positional
plagiocephaly. It's
actually very common.
It's when the baby likes
to look to the right
or the left and they
get flattening of
that side of the head.
As you can see here,
it's a parallelogram,
right? It pushes
everything else this way.
And so they can have
an abnormal shaped
head here and it's
really positional
because they like
prefer that side.
What we recommend for
patients with positional
plagiocephaly is
trying to put them
on their stomachs to
try to even out their
head or even placing
them on the opposite
side of the crib so
that way they're forced
to look on the
opposite side instead
of preferring one side,
which will also help
even out the head,
okay? There are some
abnormalities that are
pathologic in terms
of their abnormal
head shape, so that's
referred to as synostosis.
So you can have
craniosynostosis,
which can be any of
these things that you
see here. any of the
sutures, basically
what happens is they
prematurely close and
cause an abnormal shape
of the head. So the
first one that you
see all the way on
this side is a sagittal
synastosis. And basically
that the sagittal
suture closes way
earlier than the
rest of the sutures.
So that causes that
nice AP diameter to
be very elongated.
Then you have the
maytopic synestosis.
I actually had a
patient with this
where the may topic
suture right here
prematurely closed.
So then this
patient had a
triangular shaped head.
And actually, we
had referred them to
neurosurgery who
had recommended
doing a surgical
opening of the suture.
But the parent
had refused
since the baby
was so young.
They said that
some of the
complications of having
synastosis, it
actually prevents brain
growth. So especially
in this case where
the frontal lobe
would be, that could
cause problems for
him in the future.
Just things to
think about.
And of course, there's
lamboid, there's
unilateral coronal
and bilateral
coronal as well, the
synastosis types.
Okay,
back to eyes. Okay,
so now we did the
head, now we're going
to go to eyes. The
eyes, we want to look
at the red reflex,
which you guys will
go over in lab.
you want to look at
the spacing of the eyes
so if there's wide
spacing or if the
epicanthal folds are
upward or downward um if
there's any strabismus
so if one eye is
looking at you this way
and the other eye is
looking at you this
way um and they should
start babies have
terrible vision when
they're born uh newborns
but around two to four
months is really when
they start tracking
which means following
you across the room
um and tracking past
midline so tracking
like a full 180 degree
they'll start doing
that which is kind of
cool for their ears
we want to make sure
that the ears are
correctly set so not
low set or posteriorly
rotated we want to make
sure there's no pits
or tags so I have a
picture of this here so
here you want to make
sure this is this is
what an ear pit looks
like this is what
an ear tag looks like
and this is the pinna
So historically, it
was thought that ear
pits bilaterally
meant that there was
also something wrong
with your kidneys.
But now we know that
if it's an isolated
anomaly and they
just have ear pits
bilaterally, that
does not necessarily
indicate that there's
a renal abnormality.
However, if there's
more congenital things
that are concerning,
then there could be.
So that would be a
good place to check.
Then we talked about the
posterior positioning
of the ear
in reference to the
head. So your ear
should be positioned
basically along the line
of the lateral
epicanthal fold. So if
it's under that, then
we call that low set
ears, which is more
common in conditions
like genetic conditions
like Down syndrome,
and even posteriorly
rotated as well.
Then you want to do
an ear exam in the
older patients. So in
the toddlers and up,
they're very
commonly will get ear
infections. So remember,
this is what a normal
ear looks like. The
tympanic membrane
is a little bit
pale gray, purplish
color. And then there's
a nice cone of light
that's kind of
reflecting back at you.
This picture right
next to it looks very
bulgy, but it doesn't
look very red. But this
is definitely pus behind
the TM. So this is
infected. And then
here you have that nice
erythema, you have
that kind of fluid, you
have the bulging. So
this is actually serous
fluid, which is infected
fluid in the back.
So this one, these
two, you definitely
need treatment oral
antibiotics for.
You can also get
otitis externa,
which is basically
an infection
of the outer ear,
the ear canal.
And that one, you'll
see the ear canal
is erythematous, it
has discharge. And
then when you pull
on the pinna or the
tragus, you'll
actually elicit some
pain because it moves
the eustachian tube
and the ear canal
where the pain is.
Okay, going back just
slightly to the head.
So types of scalp
findings from delivery in
newborns. So there's a
couple different ones.
So you can get a cap
at secondum. So it's
like a cap. the swelling
is throughout and
usually this will cross
suture lines and it's
usually due to prolonged
delivery whether
they're stuck in the
birth canal for a while
or they use the vacuum
to get out the baby
and usually this gets
better very quickly
like one to two days. So
this is a good picture
up here of what a caput
looks like. You can
also have a cephalohematoma.
So cephalohematoma
is really restricted
to a suture line.
It does not cross.
And you can often see
bruising and skin
discoloration on top of it.
Same risk factors
due to birth canal or
vacuum assistant
delivery. And this will
take a lot longer to
go away. And actually,
a lot of blood can
accumulate there.
So you can get an
increasing amount
of jaundice as well.
So this will take
about two to four
weeks to resolve
and completely go
away. But it does.
The dangerous type is
called the subglial
hemorrhage. So this
one crosses suture
lines. A lot of
blood can accumulate
because it's in that
subglial area underneath
the glia and above
the periosteum.
So a lot of blood
can accumulate there.
You can cause anemia,
hypovolemia. On exam,
you'll have a positive
fluid wave. You'll
see that it can even
cause swelling in
the ear or even the
forehead and eyebrows.
So if it looks scary
like that, then
definitely think about
subglial hemorrhage and
you can get an
ultrasound to look at it.
And that will help you
with your diagnosis.
Okay, now eyes. So this
is what I was talking
about with the red
reflex. So the first
picture at the top
shows you what a normal
red reflex looks like.
So you can see that it's
like looking at a cat
when you're driving,
right? When the light
reflects off of their
retinas. So this is
a normal red reflex.
At the bottom, you'll
see an abnormal red
reflex where the one
side is giving you that
nice red side and the
other side is giving
you this white whitish
appearance. Some
etiologies of this include
congenital cataracts,
retinoblastoma,
chorioretinal coloboma, and
scarring from retinopathy
of prematurity.
So this patient
will definitely need
ophthalmology follow
-up. And then these
are just some of
the reactions and
the pupillary and the
blink response and
all that, uh, as
per their age. Um,
so that is also
very interesting.
Okay.
Now let's talk a
little bit about
pathologies. So
you can get neonatal
conjunctivitis,
um, and the
incidence is really
dependent on region.
It can be anywhere
from one to 21%. Um, so
you can get gonoclonal
infections by an
assyria or gonorrhea.
So if the parent
is positive for
gonorrhea, and they
give birth to the birth
canal, there can be
vertical transmission
of the bacteria
into the baby's eyes
and can cause really
bad conjunctivitis.
So they get copious
purulent discharge
with chemosis, which
just means that
reddening of the sclera
and irritation. You
can get eyelid swelling.
And this can start
up to two to four
days after birth.
So it's earlier. So
this is an earlier
infection that you'll
see. And the treatment
for this is usually
an IM dose, like
intramuscular dose
of a third generation
cephalosporin, okay?
And this is to prevent
further scarring
and even blindness.
The second kind of
infection you can get
for conjunctivitis is
chlamydia. So chlamydia
gives you a watery
discharge, not necessarily
a purulent discharge,
and it comes later.
So it starts five to
14 days from birth.
And remember that the
erythromycin ointment
that we usually give
during birth or we
put on their eyes at
birth helps prevent the
gonorrheal infections,
but does not prevent
the chlamydial ones.
So if the baby does
have positive chlamydia
conjunctivitis, they
need to be treated
with oral azithromycin
or erythromycin, but
it needs to be oral.
The other type of
infectious conjunctivitis
you can get
is HSV. So ******
virus can also cause
infectious keratitis,
which is scarring
of the cornea. So
as you see in this
bottom picture that
you can see the scar
or that haziness
that you can see of
the cornea compared
to the other side.
A lot of times
if you're unsure,
you can always
get swabs and that
can help you
determine what it is.
um and if you get um
in the hsv patient if
you if you do a
fluorescein staining you
can see little dendrites
um which which shows
you that there there's
hsv um keratitis
going on okay talked
about this slide um now
let's talk about the
nose and mouth so for
the nose uh babies are
obligate nose breathers.
So when we breathe
like this, we could
talk fight and breathe
and figure it out.
Babies, however,
cannot. So they have to
breathe through their
nose or and if they
can't, then they don't
feed well and things
like that. So that's
something you have to
keep an eye on. So
you want to make sure
both sides have patent
nares. And what I mean
by that is a pathology
called clonal
atresia. And that's when
the back of the nose
is not patent, it
actually is walled off.
And so there's not
an opening. So this
can be either
unilateral or bilateral.
Oftentimes on exams,
they'll give you
some sort of scenario
where the baby has
trouble breathing,
especially when they're
feeding, and you're
not able to pass
an NG tube down their
nose on one side.
um uh obviously if
they have both sides
affected and they're both
at trees then the baby's
going to have
cyanosis or signs of
respiratory distress
right when they're born um
so usually it's the
ones that are unilateral
that go on unchecked
uh in the beginning and
then we find out um
that they have it so
ent usually will sculpt
them to see um if
they're not this obvious
like in this picture
right here uh we'll
sculpt them to see it then
you can also have a
cleft palate so it's
very important to check
the baby's mouth and
what we do to check
the baby's mouth is we
pull gloves on we take
our pinky finger and
then slide it into their
mouth and just brush
against the roof of
their mouth in the
hard palate and I go
pretty posterior because
you can have cleft
palates in the posterior
area that can go missed
so very important to
check for cleft palate
because that can
cause the baby to not
feed well and cause them
to have infections and
things like that so
definitely need to
diagnose that. And then
you can also have a
cleft lip with the
cleft palate, which
is again, a pharyngeal
arch problem. And that
can be surgically fixed.
These babies can
breastfeed successfully.
And sometimes they
just need like either
a ****** shield or a
proper positioning.
You can also have
normal findings like an
Epstein pearl, which
is that little pearly
like little dot um
that can be seen on the
gums as well and
that's a very normal
finding in a baby
okay now let's move to
clavicles so here we did
mouth we did um we uh
did mouth and then
now we're going to do
clavicles so um for
newborns uh the clavicular
fractures from birth
are actually very
common. So I always
check the clavicles and
I go from mid line
to outer part. So you
want to make sure you're
checking for symmetry
and making sure
there's no step-offs.
So here you see on the
right side that this
patient has a right
clavicular fracture.
For this, we usually
don't do anything. We
pin the sleeve of the
arm to the onesie that
they have just to
keep their hand in a
more neutral position
and that's about it
that's all we do and
we let that heal and it
usually heals in a
couple weeks um and this
can be just birth trauma
uh and then we move
to the neck area so
the neck can be webbed
it can be short it can
have excessive skin
you can have cystic
hygroma which is that
huge lymph that you
see lymph node right
here that you see
usually that's on the
lateral side you can
also get cysts or even
torticollis which is
that spasm of the neck
muscle which causes them
to look just one way
you definitely want
to look at their neck
okay now let's move to
these following systems
one by one so upper
extremities so you
want to check for tone
you want to check for
strength you want to
make sure they have
five fingers on each
hand uh you want to make
sure that their palmar
creases are look
normal and then whether
they have a nice grasp
reflex and a nice
morrow reflex, which is
the same thing as a
startle reflex, okay?
So let's talk about
that. So for hands,
some pathologies
that you can get is
polydactyly. So
here you see that
extra little piece of
tissue that's hanging
on to the side
of the pinky, and
that's called a post
-axial polydactyly.
You can see that
there's probably no
bone in here, So you
can tie it off, like
surgically tie it
off, and eventually
that will necrose
and fall off. But if
you're unsure if
there's bone in there
or there may be
bone in there, then
you refer them to
surgery for excision.
Overlapping clenched
hands can indicate
trisomy. So 13 and 18,
so Edwards and Patel, are
common findings. You can
find overlap clenched
hands. um for feet
uh again you want to
make sure that you
have five toes on each
side so you can have
syndactyly which is that
fusion of the second
and third toe um you
can also get club feet
so it's called the
official word is bilateral
aquinas deformities
um and that can also
be related to genetic
conditions or if it's
isolated or unilateral
sometimes that's that's
all the anomaly you
have um that usually
requires ortho follow
-up it's possible they
put them in a brace or
they do lengthening
exercises with the baby
to see if they can help
it um okay so now we
got to the chest so
let's talk about the
chest now we're going to
talk about deformities
heart and lung sounds
then we're going to
move to the abdomen
we're going to talk about
the gu area the lower
extremities the back
and then lastly talk
about reflexes and
then the skin all right
we're on our way. So,
newborn exam for chest.
So, you want to look
at any abnormalities
or any morphologies
of the chest that are
abnormal. So, here,
this little knob that
you see here is actually
just a prominent
xiphoid, and that's a
very normal finding.
You can get a pectus
escovatum, so
that's when the
chest wall of
the rib cage
is a little bit indented.
So, this can obviously
exacerbate any
respiratory symptoms
that the patient can have
and look a lot worse
than what it actually
is. But something
good to note in your
exam. You can also
have a supernumerary
******, which is along
the midclavicular
****** line, but you'll
just have extra either
distal to it or
proximal to the actual
******. So that's a
supernumerary ******.
Remember that
for babies, their
pulses are very fast.
So 120 to 160 is
a normal pulse for
a newborn baby.
In terms of feeling
for their vessels,
their pulses, distal
pulses, you want
to check two main
places. So the
femoral pulses are
very important to check
because if they're
not strong and
they're not bilateral
or equal, you're
worried about
coarctation of the aorta.
So for that, I usually
mobilize the thighs
outward so I can take
my two finger pads and
go right in the inguinal
crease and try to
feel it. And I try to
imagine my head a faster
heartbeat so I can try
to catch the pulse,
okay? The other spot
to go is the brachial
area, so like right
here in the inside of
the elbow, and that's
a great place to check
for baby pulses as
well. That's a good
strong one. The karate
is a little bit hard
because babies just
have a larger head and a
smaller neck, so the
brachial and the femoral
are much easier to
elicit in babies. Okay.
Then the abdomen. So in
the abdomen, we have,
we can check for
hepatospletomegaly, which
is found in a lot
of torch infections.
And also we can check
for abdominal masses
and hernias. So
neuroblastoma, Wilms tumor,
those are all masses
that you can feel
in the abdominal exam.
And then umbilical
hernias, inguinal
hernias are all, um, uh,
things that you can
also feel in their exam.
So it's normal to have
a little bit of, um,
you could feel a little
bit more liver in
babies. So we, we say
like anything to like
less than two centimeters
is normal. Anything
above, um, is not
normal. So you can feel a
little bit of liver.
This is definitely
enlarged. Um, but a
little bit is absolutely
fine, including a spleen
tip in the beginning.
Okay, let's talk
about a little bit
about umbilical cord
care. So remember,
they will, the
OBs will clamp the
umbilical cord
and then cut it.
The umbilical cord
consists of two umbilical
arteries and one
umbilical vein. So you
want to make sure that
you have those two
and two arteries and
one vein. If you only
have one one, that's
associated with genetic
abnormalities and
conditions. So that's
important to know. So
please make sure you look
at the umbilical cord
and make sure there's
two arteries and one
vein. It usually falls
off on its own in
about 10 to 14 days. So
the umbilicus cannot
get infected during
that time. So we suggest
that the baby is not
submerged in water until
the umbilicus falls
off. So this is a
great schematic here on
the progression of
what it looks like when
the umbilical cord
falls off um some things
that sometimes people
will do is cover it
so we'll put like a
band-aid or something
over it and that actually
is anitis for infection
so i'm encouraging
parents not to do
that some of the
abnormalities you can get
with umbilicus is an
umbilical hernia so this
down here is an
umbilical hernia this is
just weakening of the
abdominal muscles and
it gets better around
three to six years of
age and we don't really
need to do anything
as long as it's
compressible and reducible.
So I just push those
things right back in.
And I tell the
parents if this ever
comes becomes hard,
or you can't push it
in or becomes red
or painful, then go
to the emergency
room. Okay, then you
can also have an
umbilical granuloma.
So this will have
leaking like fluid.
And it'll look like
this when you open
up the belly button
a little bit. And
for this, we usually
do silver nitrate
cauterization to
close this granuloma,
okay?
You can also
get infection of
the actual
umbilicus itself.
So that needs IV
antibiotics in a
newborn. So if there's
any concern for
that, you also
need to be careful.
And then if there's
prolonged bleeding
around that site,
that's also something
to keep in the back
of your mind, which
could be related to
a bleeding disorder.
If there's delayed
separation, so it
takes more than two
weeks for the umbilical
cord to fall off,
then there is an
immuno, um, immuno,
uh, disorder that, um,
it takes longer,
longer for granulocytes
to even come to
the place of, of
inflammation. And this
could be a reason why.
So all things to
kind of keep in mind.
Okay. Let's talk about
heart rate. So, um,
remember it's very
hard to hear murmurs,
um, because the heart
rate is so fast. So,
um, I listened for a
full 60 seconds and
I I know it scares
some parents because
they're not used to
people listening to their
heart for that long,
their baby's heart.
But I will listen
for the whole 60
seconds and I will
listen in multiple spots.
It's the same thing
that you're doing
in adults, right?
You're doing APTM,
but I'm listening
in all those spots.
And a lot of times
you can hear you
can hear heart
sounds from the back,
too, in babies
because they just have
a very small chest
and cavity. Right.
So we usually grade
murmurs from one to six,
one being the softest.
and six being like,
I can feel a murmur
even from without a
stethoscope on you. Um,
so a thrill, I mean, like,
like adventitious,
uh, heart sounds, you,
the murmurs can be either
systolic or diastolic.
So depending upon
where the murmur falls,
where you hear that
extra whooshing sound,
um, and sometimes they
will get better with
positioning versus
not. Some of the, um,
more dangerous, uh,
etiologies will usually be
accompanied with
cyanosis or a blowing of
the skin, okay? And down
here is a good schematic
of different color
skin tones and what
cyanosis may look like
in them. The nail beds
and the gums are a
great place to look for
cyanosis if the skin
is not evident to you.
This, I thought, was
a good chart with
murmurs. So, if it's a
soft murmur and it's a
stoic and it gets louder
when they're supine,
which then, you know,
brings the blood
back in therefore making
it louder and their
otherwise cardiac
exam is totally normal
then and they don't
have any risk factors
for structural heart
disease you can say this
is an innocent murmur
likely and just kind
of keep an eye on it
versus any of these
dangerous things like
you know it's loud
three out of six or
it's diastolic or has a
click or a fixed s2
it becomes louder with
standing so when
there's decreased blood
or there's radiations
or carotids we have to
refer them to the
pediatric cardiologist.
One of the high used
things in pediatrics
is the PDA. So a PDA will
give you a continuous
murmur throughout
systole and diastole.
For lung sounds, usually
respiratory rates
for infants is 30 to
60. So if you think
it's a murmur, just
make sure it's not
their breathing because
sometimes that can
trick you as well.
Using their accessory
muscles, so like the
muscles between the
ribs or right under
the subcostal region.
So all areas where
you can see respiratory
distress. In kids
specifically, you'll
see nasal flaring
as well, like flaring
in and out when they're
breathing. And that's
a common sign of
respiratory distress
in babies as well.
Okay, hip exam.
So hip dysplasia
is a problem with
development of the
absetabulum and the
connection and joint
between the hip.
So what happens is
we do these tests to
figure out if this
patient has hip dysplasia.
Risk factors
include if they're
female, they're
breech, and they
have positive
family history.
So there's two techniques
that we do. It's
called Bartlow,
Barlow, and Orilani. So
Orilani, you're going
to go out, and Barlow,
you're going to come
back. so um what you're
gonna do is you're gonna
use your middle finger
to uh be right above
the hip bone right
on it and your knees
are gonna stay um sorry
your thumbs are gonna
be on your knees so
you're gonna use your
index finger to stabilize
the thigh and that's
what's gonna help
you go out and then back
in okay Arlani Barlow
okay um and so you're
what you're trying
to do is displace the
hip and it will be easy
if they have hip
dysplasia to to displace
it and you'll feel a
clunk in your in your
hands versus if they
have stable joint space
between their hips and
they you won't feel
a clunk you may feel a
click or you may feel
nothing at all and
that's normal okay
another sign that I
could tell you whether
there's hip dysplasia so
this bottom picture is
is an example of what
an x-ray looks like.
So, you can see that on
this side, you have the
epiceal plate, the
growth plate, and then
you have that curving
of the area where
the acetabulum will
go. Here, you see
a little bit of
flattening, and then you
don't see that growth
plate here, okay?
So, that's abnormal.
It should be even.
So, you'll see asymmetry
of the gluteal or
the thigh skein folds.
You can also do a
Gillesi test, which
the specificity is low
and it can be
present about 25% of
unaffected infants. But
the Gillesi test is you
keep their feet on
the exam table and you
put their knees up
and you check for
asymmetry of the knees.
Okay, so that's good.
If they're younger
than four months,
we can do a bilateral
hip ultrasound
to check for the
joint area. If
they're after four
months, that's
when we do the
bilateral hip x-rays.
Okay, for the back,
we want to check
for spina bifida,
which is basically
where the spinal
cord is exposed and
the spinal fluid
can come out as well
as the spinal cord.
So you can have a
myelomeningocele
or a meningocele.
You can have a
sacral dimple or a
cleft. So in these
cases, you absolutely
want to get an
ultrasound of the
back to make sure
that they don't have
like spinal cord
in that in that
pocket. That's
very important. And
this needs to be
surgically fixed.
Okay,
GU exam. So for
females, we want
to make sure that
***** are not
fused and there's
no clitoromegaly.
It's normal to have
a little bit of white
vaginal discharge or
even a little bit of
blood. And that's just
from mom's hormones. For
males, we want to make
sure that testicular
exam shows that both
of the ****** are
descended into the
*******. Otherwise, it's
called crypt organism,
and that's when the
******** is stuck up in
the inguinal canal. And
it usually does not
come down if it's very
high. It has to be
surgically brought down.
For urethra, you want
to look at whether
it's placed properly.
So for example,
they shouldn't have
hypospadias or epispadias
hypo means it's
under where it's
supposed to be and epi
means it's above um
so we have to
make sure that
the place the
the placement of
the urethra is
right um on top
excuse me for the
scrotal *** um we want
to make sure there's
no bifid so for example
it should be connected
so this one is
a bifid um which
means that there's a
little uh indent right
here which should not
be. So it kind of
looks like female
genitalia, but it's
actually male genitalia. So
this is an ambiguous
genitalia patient.
Remember that one-sided
*********** of the
******** can sometimes
be a hydrocele. And
the way you know if
it's a hydrocele is you
have a positive
transillumination test,
which means that if you
put a light right under
it, you'll see that
it's clear like this,
which means it's filled
with fluid and not
******** or solid mass
or varicose, okay?
In both, you want to
make sure that the
**** is patent because
if there's an imperfect
****, this is a medical
emergency and you
have to surgically
fix that. So there
should always, always
be an **** present and
patent. So make sure
you're checking that.
If the patient has
ambiguous genitalia, you
have to rule out congenital
adrenal hyperplasia
because that's also
a serious condition
where the patient can
get hypoglycemic or
even be severely
dehydrated because the
other hormones are being
shifted all towards
the *** hormones. And
you guys will learn
about congenital adrenal
hyperplasia as well.
Okay, now the fun part.
So the neurological
and developmental
newborn exam. So you
want to check for the
tone. You want to check
for whether they're
hyper or hypotonic.
And either one can be
bad for different
reasons um and then you
definitely want to
check for primitive
reflexes which we'll
we'll go through um just
remember that overall
regression is usually
bad so that means they
were doing something
before but now they're
no longer doing
it that's usually a
very bad indication
okay so let's look
at the primitive uh
reflexes so as you can
see in this top picture
this is checking
for head lag. So the
picture here, A is a
very, very newborn, B
is a four month old,
and then C is a six
month old. So you
can tell that they're
increasing in their
strength and their ability
to keep their head
and trunk up, right?
So like,
basically, they're
doing a pull up, right?
Then you see over
here, this patient
is having a marrow
reflex. So that's
when both of the
hands like fan out.
It's also called
the startle reflex.
You can also put them
on their backs. And
so when they're
newborn, they're not
really doing anything
will be when they're
a month old, they
can start lifting a
little bit. And by three
months, they should
be kind of three or
four months, they
should be lifting their
head way up. Okay.
Remember the pincer
grass that we
talked about,
that will really
finalize around
nine to 12 months.
Otherwise, they're
using a rake. So like
going like this and
grabbing at things, but not
using that fine grasp
that you see in usually
nine months of age
to 12 months of age.
Over here at the bottom,
you'll see a fencing
position. So that's
the atonic neck reflex.
And that one will go
over as well. So here
are the primitive
reflexes so the moral
reflex the startle reflex
that we said here it's
it starts at birth so
um with newborn babies
sometimes you just
have to close the door
or listen to them to
be able to elicit the
startle reflex so it
happens actually very
quickly um and it
disappears by by by about
four months of age um
hand grasps also present
at birth and it goes
away at three months
then the cross adductor
presents at birth and
then disappears about
seven months the toe
grass or the plantar
reflex is present at
birth and goes away
about eight to 15 months.
The atonic neck reflex,
which is the one
I showed you here,
that starts at about
two weeks and then
disappears by about
six months. The
parachute reflex, the
equilibrium reflex,
and the head rightening
reflex all persist
past into adulthood.
For fine motor tasks,
we usually define
that by either stacking
blocks or by scribbles
so um it takes a
while to get there
so they'll start
scribbling at about 15
months um and two two
years they'll start
doing vertical and
circular strokes by three
years they start
doing circles so think
three circle four they
do a cross so four
points four cross
like four years five
they do they can copy
a square and remember
six is uh sorry
The triangle is the
hardest one. And so
that one is also after
five that they will
get. So that one is a
is a higher development
fine motor task.
okay let's talk about
skin so number one is
infantile eczema so
remember eczema in babies
happens more so on
the face so in the
cheeks is a very common
place to see infantile
eczema also in the
flexor services instead
of the extensor
services like we see in
adults so in the anti
-cubital area and also
the anterior knee area
for this we usually
prescribe emollients
which is the mainstay
treatment but also we
can prescribe steroids.
Number two is a
hemangioma so this is a
benign growth of
capillaries and this usually
gets bigger before
it gets smaller and
then eventually goes
away. It can take
years for it to regress
completely and go
away but it doesn't
scar so that's good.
There's two cases in
which you have to give
them treatment for
it. So one, if it's
obscuring their eye
or their vision, or
two, if it's in their
vocal cords in the
airway and they're causing
obstruction, because
remember, they will
get bigger, right?
So in those cases, you
have to do treatment,
and usually we treat
with propanolol.
Three is cradle caps, so
seborrhebic dermatitis,
and that one has
that flaky kind of
dandruffy look to it,
and it can also extend up
to the ears and eyebrows
as well. For this,
we usually recommend
doing baby oils and
then combing out some
of those flakes um and
then washing the hair
and it's going to come
back and we do it again
but relatively very
benign um pathology
um and it gets better
with time four is aniva
simplex so this is
your classic stork bite
or angel's kiss the
glabella is a very
common place the eye is
common place and then
the back of the neck is
a very common place
to get these these are
also very very benign
um five etox so erythema
toxicum neonatrum this
one it looks scary
uh but it's actually
very benign as well
it's these little
papules and surrounding
erythema um and this shows
up a couple days after
birth um and for this
if you were to do a
biopsy you would find
eosinophils which is
for some reason nobody
would take a biopsy.
But if they did, that's
what you would find.
But that's generally a
test question. I don't
know why they like
to ask you guys that.
Six, pustular melanosis.
So six, this will
actually happen
pretty early on. So
within a couple hours
of birth, and you'll
get these small
pustules that will then
pop and then become sort
of like hyperpigmented
melanotic areas
like this. It kind
of looks like freckles,
but they're not.
Then number seven
is congenital dermal
melanocytosis,
previously called
Mongolian spots,
and that can happen
more often in
colored skin tones.
Eight is milia. So
you see all these nice
small sebaceous
glands. Those are all
milia, and that is
very benign as well.
Their skin is just trying
to figure out what to do.
Okay, let's talk a little
bit about jaundice.
So normal newborns
have physiological
jaundice, which means
that they're not
eating enough and their
enzyme in their liver
is still working on
conjugating. So what
can happen is there
can be buildup of
unconjugated bilirubin
and that can cause
jaundice to their skin,
like you see here.
This is a good somatic
of how jaundice
levels, as they
increase, you'll see more
and more of their body
becoming jaundice.
So that's fun to look at.
As their liver
enzymes get better and
their hemolysis improves,
then that bilirubin
gets turned into
conjugated and then
can be excreted in
their feces and urine.
So the more they eat,
the more they pee
and poop, the better
they get. If they're
bilirubin, and we
use Billy Tool to
assess for whether
this patient needs
phototherapy. So serum
bilis on this side
and And then postnatal
age is on this side.
And it will give
you, will pinpoint
exactly where this
patient stands. And if
they're high risk,
then we put them into
the box like this.
It's an incubator.
Isolet, and that has
blue lights that are UV
lights. It's different
than sunlight UV
rays, but similar in
that they use UV lights
to actually change
the composition of
unconjugated to conjugated
bilirubin so that they
can excrete it properly.
They usually wear
these little goggles
to protect their eyes,
and they usually have
diapers on so they
don't pee all over the
bed. We do take them
out to breastfeed, etc.,
but we put them back
as soon as we're done.
And they usually stay
in there until their
jaundice or their
bilirubin levels start
to kind of fall, okay?
All right, so for
children up to five,
If you want to ask about
milestone questions,
like we talked
about, gross motor,
fine motor, language,
social, emotional.
Are they running?
Are they using two
steps to walk up
the stairs? Are
they using one step?
Can they hop on
one foot? Can they
ride a tricycle?
Things like that.
For screenings,
we check for MCHAT
scoring, which is a
questionnaire that
we give at 18 months
and 24 months.
We do an ages and
questions questionnaire
at nine months, 18
months and 30 months.
The MCHAT is really
for social-emotional
interactions, so that's
a test for autism.
And really, at each
visit, you want to
surveillance the
developmental milestones,
but there's official
time periods
where you want to do
official screenings,
like was previously
mentioned up here.
I also like to
know how's school
going, how's
daycare going, are
they interacting
well with others,
are they throwing
tantrums, which is very
common, and how you
are dealing with them.
um safety questioning
like are there any
guns in the home is
there anyone smoking in
the home are they
wearing seat belts in um
are they using their
car seat their booster
seats helmets while
riding bikes are
there smoke detectors
in the house are there
smoke um carbon monoxide
detectors and uh
poison control
information for toddlers
because they will put
everything in their mouth
no matter what it is
um so uh that could
be medication that
could be you know drugs
things like that so um
Always baby proofing
the house, especially
around that time
where they're starting
to explore a lot and
get to know a lot of
their surroundings.
So locking away meds,
cabinet, putting
covers on ovens and
so they're not able to
get in to them and
putting a lock on the
toilet so they don't
fall into the toilet.
All those things
are great ways
of baby proofing
the house.
Um, then you can also
do, uh, we also do
hearing and vision
screenings in the clinic
when they're about
three or four years
of age. And then the
AP recommends lead and
iron testing at one
year of age. Uh, we
also, at my old clinic,
we used to do it
at the two year mark
as well. Um, but the
guidelines really say
at one year. And then
if it's abnormal,
you can do it at two
year, but you don't
have to. Uh, we also
started doing BP
measurements at three. Um,
and we usually start
are talking about
toilet training
around 18 months or
so, usually when
the child is ready,
that's when we start
actually doing toilet
training. It's really
up to the child to
kind of guide that.
They have to be able
to stay without
wetting themselves and
tell the parent when
they're having either
bowel movements or
urinating. So those
things need to fall in
place before we start
thinking about toilet
training for kids.
The four stages of car
safety. So they should
be rear facing up
until about two years
of age or until the
height or weight that this
says on the car seat
then we turn them
forward facing we turn
them forward facing um
and then we uh change
them to a booster seat
usually by five um and
again we're this is
all to make sure that
the seat belt is is
sitting properly against
their bodies and then
once they're over 10
um they can they can
be safely moved to
without a booster seat.
Sometimes it's eight
years old. So eight
to 10 really depends
on how big the
infant, I mean, the
kid is, but really
the whole point is
to get the seatbelt
over their shoulder
and over their lap.
So that's the goal.
This is what the MCHAT
and the DSM-5 criteria
for autism spectrum
disorder looks like. So
as you can see, there's
a lot of social
emotional deficits in
people with autism so
they also do stereotypical
repetitive movements
they have trouble
maintaining understanding
relationships their
non-verbal communication
often they use for
social interaction and
they're usually very
sensitive to send to
different sensory objects
they also like to
be highly fixated to
one or intensely focus
on one thing um yeah
and then there's mild
impairment there's
moderate impairment and
severe impairment so
it's not only always the
cause the case um okay
some tricks and tips
so ears and mouth you
should do last if
possible because that's
what's going to get
them the most irritated
so the best way to to
stabilize the baby's
head um is to use your
hand and then use your
hand to stabilize
against the baby's cheek
so that you're not
hovering with your scope
that you're looking
with a very intentional
aspect and then here
I have a picture of
the patient the parent
actually helping you
hold them which makes
your job a lot easier
so this is a perfect
way to examine a baby is
to have the parent be
like hug them so that
their hands are covered
and then hold their
head and then all you
have to do is make
sure you're stable and
then look in the ear.
For their oral
examination,
I have them hold them,
bear hug them, and
then hold one head
like this so that I
can look in their
mouth and use a tongue
depressor. What I
usually do is go from the
side, not the front,
because if you go in
from the front, if
they have teeth,
they're just going to
bite down. So going from
the side and then
kind of opening their
mouth sometimes can
get you a good exam.
This is the number
for poison control.
We want to encourage
our patients to
read. Remember,
they're getting teeth
at this time too.
So, um, they start by
getting their
central incisors at
about six months and
then they start moving
and getting more
teeth as they go.
Um,
then we have the WIC
program, which provides
mothers and infants,
a lot of resources,
including formula,
breastfeeding utensils, um,
uh, specialized foods
for babies as well.
Um,
toilet training,
again we talked about
but um that's also
something that uh that
they can start
doing after 18 to 24
months of age and
that's it thank you for
watching if you have
any questions you can
always email me and
please fill out the
feedback lecture
form so i know how i
did thank you and
these are my resources